par exemple christophe girard dans son
communiqué de presse deux des missions
de la la mairie de paris
il brandit le maccarthysme donc c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que quand
on parle d'un qu'ils y sion on va
stigmatiser l'inquisition là où la
censure aux états unis alors qu'on en a
déjà aussi dans notre histoire française
il va brandir sa mais quelque part c'est
pour une manière de ne pas parler de ne
pas discuter de fer etc rendre à sa
responsabilité politique et personnel
donc moi je trouve ça intéressant tu
toujours et on l'avait vu aussi face à
bittou sur la liberté d'importuner que
on va opposer ses droits fondamentaux
que sont la liberté et l'égalité comme
si on avait à choisir entre l'un et
l'autre
or comment est-ce qu'on pourrait être
vraiment libre si on n'est pas égaux
donc moi là dessus je trouve qu'il ya
vraiment deux poids deux mesures sur le
fait qu'on dise qu'on asf effacés
christophe girard ou gabriel matzneff
alors qu'eux ils ont quand même été dans
l'impunité très longtemps ou polanski
qui est pourtant a été condamnée est
encore libre alors qu'on va pas parler
par exemple ou très peu ou en tout cas
on va pas utiliser ce terme de cancelles
culture pour rokhaya diallo une affaire
très récente pour alice coffin qui a
subi un cyber harcèlement
donc là dessus moi je suis assez gêné
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle de
d'effacement de cancelles culture
uniquement comme ça on concerne la
remise en code de comportement raciste
sexiste pédophiles et non pas quand ça
touche des personnes qui au contraire
portent ces enjeux qui sont au coeur
normalement de la mise en oeuvre des
fameux droits de l'homme
[Musique]